it's been a few months since Intel
launched their Arc serious graphics
cards and while it started off in a bit
of a rough State Intel has been working
hard to address their flaws now early
reviews were critical of their
inconsistent performance and relatively
high power consumption and the company
has been dropping the prices of its
models in particular this Intel Arc a750
is now the same price as the entry-level
AMD Radeon RX 6600 which is supposed to
rival nvidia's RTX 3060 and even the
3060 TI with newer drivers being updated
Intel might be onto something and they
have shown significant improvements in
some key titles so much so that Intel
arc graphics cards could be the answer
for more budget-friendly PCS so is the
Intel Arc a750 worth buying in 2023 well
what we have here is a custom PC built
by the Volkswagen Aftershock and it's
powered by this very own graphics card
alright let's talk about how the
interarc a750 performs with its new
updates as of this video but before we
get into it this channel is supported by
Brands who help us improve our content
and keep us going so stay around for
this sponsored message here at geek
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but Secret Life gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of four
men function helps the Titan Evo 2020 to
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co alright guys so as
mentioned before we are testing the
interarc a750 with this custom built PC
all thanks to the folks over at
Aftershock PC now specs wise we are
running this on a 12th gen Intel i5
12400 CPU 32 gigabytes of RAM and a 980
Pro m.2 and vme SSD I would say this
runs you a mid-spec PC so we should be
able to run most games at 2K 60fps but
we'll see how it plays out on more heavy
workloads on top of all that I just got
a reference monitor here because you
guys will be seeing this monitor live we
are not going to run any OBS or any
recording devices because we wouldn't
want to text the system so with that
let's start off with Apex Legends
alright folks so we're going to be
running Apex Legends right now and we
can see our our base temperature is 50
degrees Celsius we're running pretty
smoothly for now because we're on the
main menus now let's go and check the
settings real quick just to see what
we're running off now for the most part
this game has been optimized by the
Intel art control center so let's just
see what we have here video settings
we're running this natively at 2K some
interesting settings here triple
buffered vsync tsaa anti-aliasing with
most of the other stuff on low disabled
model detail low effects detail low with
only impact marks and ragdolls being
high so let's just give it a shot and
see what we can get out of it okay it's
done in the game real quick here we're
running at a very smooth 60 FPS
so guys if if you're seeing a very bad
gameplay right now I'm just running a
really small monitor
ah
[Laughter]
sorry that was so bad one more time
albeit a very short match uh we're
running pretty smoothly so let's bump up
the
details I'm just gonna bring model
details and effects details to medium
it's just gonna be a tad hot
playing the game oh shoots no no no
round three all right Xeno is gonna be
playing the game all right dinner has
just landed we're still playing it very
smoothly right now at 60 FPS GPU memory
utilization that's at 79 percent
just dropped a little bit on FPS
to about 56
even with all the smoke effects too
they're still running very smoothly nice
run
all right so if you can tell from the
very badly done three rounds that the
game actually holds up pretty well into
our control center has really optimized
the game well with it witness some minor
screen tests but overall the game still
looks great even on low from what it's
one of the GPU still handles this game
pretty pretty well so let's move on to
the next one okay so we are here playing
my favorite game did Island two let's go
through the display settings real quick
still running natively at 2K a full
screen v-sync maximum maximum frame rate
60 and for the most part we are on the
medium preset so let's just see how it
goes
yeah
oh nice
whoa
still running pretty well pretty
smoothly too
got a few little things here in the
right environment
you can get away zombie
finish him
get they oh
so now we are in a more open environment
here
running through the streets
of Los Angeles
they're running at 53 now 54 57
[Music]
still playable on high
there we go
54 FPS 55 pfps
there we go nice
all right so I think it's pretty
clear-cut that the Intel Arc e750 is
actually running pretty smoothly even on
high at 2K still got very rich
environments minor frame drops but I
think it holds up pretty well so let's
move on to the next all right so that's
just the taste of gaming live let's walk
through some in-game benchmarks first we
got return on probably one of the most
insanely good multi-part benchmarks from
particles to mesh complexity and it's
pretty impressive to see how returner
performs on this of course we start out
with return on 4K at medium settings
just to see how far we can push the
graphics card and boy this game actually
ramps up the GPA load at 100 we are
still getting pretty high Edition frames
cut at 60 frames per second now stepping
down on the quality we have 2K
resolution High preset quality with X
ESS on balance and Ray tracing on low
hitting an average of 61 FPS and just to
see how well it performs on 1080p with
medium Ray tracing hitting an average of
7 70 FPS now next up is shadow of the
Tomb Raider Definitive Edition running
with DirectX 12 with the game actually
handing itself better than I expected to
be honest we've managed to pull off an
average of 88 frames per second at the
highest preset with X ESS on that list
as well now furthermore we've reached a
whopping average of 128 FPS on the
lowest graphic settings and it comes as
no surprise that the a750 would be able
to handle older games here and finally
something for you RPG fans with Final
Fantasy 14 and Walker Benchmark which
you do a score of 16 026 and it just you
know it celebrates you with extremely
high performance quality 2K resolution
so
so as you can see from the performance
alone it's pretty obvious that the e750
can handle modern games like return on
Dead Island 2 and more and that tells us
that Intel is making steps in the right
direction and that's encouraging for a
platform that's not as mature as AMD and
Nvidia so it's exciting to see a third
entry in the market the a750 isn't just
another GPU that will just scrape by at
minimum quality especially if you
consider that we are running these games
on 1440p and this means that it will
cook pretty well at 1080p with the
higher settings and will do so with less
sweat than some of its costlier
counterparts now with that said video
editing will be a juicy Target but
gaming has been Intel's focus with The
Arc GPU so far and they are already
doing some pretty interesting things
when it comes to video encoding but this
is only supported by a handful of
applications right now so do let us know
down in the comment section if you like
to see us test this with content
creation as we'll leave that for another
video with that said I highly recommend
the Intel art a750 if you're looking for
a graphics card that offers good value
or if you're just looking for a good
entry-level GPU in general this works so
that's the interarc a750 in a nutshell
can't wait to see how well it performs
over the coming months don't forget to
give us a like and do consider
subscribing it goes a long way we'll see
you on the next one